one of southern nevada's most popular
areas for hiking climbing or just
enjoying nature could eventually see
some changes we are talking about calico
basin right near red rock canyon a plan
from the bureau of land management aims
to protect the environment sasha loftis
joins us now with the details denise and
brian a lot of the reason people say
they love calico basin is because it's
free and easy to access those we spoke
with say they're not sure they want to
see that change
we're out here every day almost angela
steffen calls calico basin her sanctuary
and counts on the spot to unwind that's
being kind of our church and our place
to come and
exercise and just get grounded she's one
of many who uses these trails that are
free and open anytime
but the bureau of land management
approved an area management plan this
week that could bring some changes there
are
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people that come out and use
this area the goal of the proposal is to
balance a surge in visitors while also
protecting the land fees and a
reservation system could also come into
play
brian friesen president of southern
nevada climbers association says that
could paint a different picture from
what calico basin offers now this is one
of the most easily accessible areas for
climbing there's no fee currently
and you can come out here after work and
enjoy the beautiful scenery he says the
group is still digesting the plan we
need to preserve this land and to many
people it can look
in many different ways but regardless of
what happens
he and stefan hope every person does
their part to protect this refuge
right in our backyard we want to keep it
preserved and have it really beautiful
there is a 30 day appeal period open
before the blm can move forward here if
you'd like to weigh in we have a link on
our website eight news now dot com